[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de la rédaction voici
les titres de ce 14 mars 2010 est une
conférence sur la question du
harcèlement était organisée lundi soir
au chesnay en présence de nora frias
mère d'une adolescente est victime la
région s'interroge sur le financement
des transports et c'est le pass navigo
qui pourrait augmenter les explications
et suivrait le point sur les autres
pistes envisagées
et puis chaque mardi nous vous proposons
de découvrir un yves launoy rencontre
aujourd'hui avec fred oddou chez
monsieur loyal du cirque zavatta en
représentation voici quelques semaines à
l'île des loisirs à saint quentin en
yvelines
dans l'actualité du jour ses salariés
d'edf en garde à vue dans les locaux de
la police à saint germain en laye ils
sont une demi douzaine être soupçonné
d'avoir détourné plus de 700000 euros
sous forme de faux remboursement à des
clients du fournisseur d'électricité une
manoeuvre mise en place dès 2014 les
interpellations se sont déroulées
notamment à montigny le bretonneux mais
aussi à versailles et aux mureaux elle
les enquêteurs ont découvert dans les
différents domiciles de nombreux les
objets de luxe
les pompiers étaient dans la rue cet
après midi à l'appel de plusieurs
organisations syndicales ils ont défilé
à paris entre république et nation afin
de dénoncer leurs conditions de travail
et le manque de moyens matériels et
humains
écoutez à ce sujet le vice président du
syndicat autonome des pompiers des
yvelines nous l'avons joint par
téléphone alors de la manifestation
aujourd'hui la politique nationale de la
sécurité civile à la française et dévoué
sur le pompier volontaire qui est lui un
engagement certain mais qui n'est pas
disponible à son concentrent ce qui
donne donc des contraintes de personnel
avec des sur engagement en effectifs et
des problèmes de départ de secours de
manque de moyens techniques que humains
lessa sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
propos recueillis par nicolas
kirillovitch elle ce sujet de société à
présent le harcèlement à l'école une
conférence sur la question vient de se
tenir au chesnay avec un témoignage
bouleversant celui de
or à fraisses le 13 février elle
retrouvait sa fille de 13 ans pendu dans
une lettre elle s'adressait à ses
camarades de classe qui l'avait harcelée
selon l'unicef 28 % des adolescents elle
dit avoir déjà pensé au suicide
en france le reportage de haussmann
vendeurs d de patrick jacques de dixmude
voici quatre ans quatre ans que marion
fraysse a mis fin à ses jours par
pendaison suite du harcèlement scolaire
depuis sa mère nora se bat avec son
association marion les mains tendues
elle se déplace dans tous les
établissements pour sensibiliser les
parents sur ce fléau et diffuse aux
familles un téléfilm qui retrace le
parcours tragique de sa fille souvent
les gens sont démunis sont pas tous
concernés mais sont tous touchés par le
phénomène
certains vous diront ah c'est pas mon
enfant mais moi même je l' ai vécu où
j'ai été borderline ou d'autres vont
dire je suis grand parents comment doit
réagir face aux écrans géants un
faisceau d'indicés parce que vous croyez
qu'ils se passent telle ou telle chose
il faut lever les doutes
comment porter plainte qui contacter
c'est quoi le harcèlement
voilà c'est mettre des mots sur un
phénomène qui aujourd'hui
un prochain élèves sur dix en france
selon les statistiques quatre
adolescents se suiciderait chaque année
à cause des cyber 1 seulement 61 % des
élèves disent avoir des idées de suicide
un fléau qui concerne autant les parents
que les enfants 30 quand elle
s'il ya un problème pas parce que des
fois l'enfant dit rien et je les suis de
trois heures de trois ans après que mon
fils était tapé embêtait à l'école donc
ce qu'ils voulaient une psychologue pour
autre chose et il a fait un dessin et
non c'est comme ça qu'on l'a su donc
voilà j'attends de voir un petit peu le
parcours des familles qui sont touchées
par le harcèlement et essayer de
comprendre s'il y aurait pas quelque
chose pour pour prévenir du harcèlement
essayer de trouver des remèdes avant le
suicide
22% des enfants harcelés n'en parle à
personne pour lutter contre ce fléau le
gouvernement a mis un site en place non
au harcèlement point education.gouv.fr
vous pouvez aussi contacter des
professionnels aux 30 20 la fédération
du secours populaire des yvelines a fêté
ses 50 ans ce samedi 11 mars dans la
salle du scarabée à la verrière une
soirée destinée aux bénévoles et aux
donateurs des yvelines animé par un
groupe la blouse family un invité de
marque julien lauprêtre et c'est le
président du secours populaire en france
au micro de nicolas landry je suis avec
beaucoup d'attention ce que nos
bénévoles et nos amis font dans les
yvelines
ils ont un bilan remarquable je suis
plus un président qui va voir que ce qui
se passe est un président de bureau
donc ma présence ici c'est pour les
féliciter de tout ce qu'ils apportent à
la solidarité leur montrer que bonds qui
a les yvelines mais quand s'est joint à
tout ce qui se passe dans le pays
c'est la plus grande des associations de
solidarité dans notre pays nous parlons
transport dans un instant et cette
hausse du passe navigo envisagée par la
région en attendant un mot concernant la
pollution de l'air elle s'est un peu
amélioré ce mardi en ile de france
comparativement à lundi selon airparif
en charge de sa surveillance
mais le niveau des polluants demeure
assez proche du seuil d alerte pour
mercredi cette amélioration devrait tout
de même se confirme et de nouvelles
mesures doivent encore intervenir avant
elle la prise de décision concernant la
circulation alternée ou encore le
stationnement se dirige-t-on vers une
nouvelle hausse du tarif unique du passe
navigo la question est clairement posée
depuis une semaine maintenant et cette
table ronde organisée par le syndicat
des transports en ile de france le stif
cette table-ronde organisée autour du
financement des transports publics
où étaient présentes notamment valérie
pécresse présidente de la région
plusieurs spécialistes également et ce
constat est nicolas le stif a besoin de
trouver rapidement de nouvelles recettes
en effet où ils fruits dont on va parler
franchement il va manquer de l'argent
dans les caisses du stif pour assumer
les ambitions de la région en terme
d'investissement c'était déjà le cas
l'an passé avec cette eau se
souvenez-vous de 3 euros du prix du pass
navigo c'était en août 2016 et bien la
situation va continuer de se tendre pour
les finances du stif entre 2017 et 2030
le style va investir environ 20
milliards d'euros dans les transports
franciliens avec par exemple 700
nouvelles rames promesse de campagne de
valérie pécresse la création de
nouvelles lignes comme le tram 13
express dans les civils et puis il ya
aussi l'arrivée du grand paris express
en 2023 il faudra assurer l'entretien et
le fonctionnement de 200 km de métro
supplémentaires et du coup nicolas c'est
le pass navigo le prix du pass navigo
qui pourrait augmenter alors rien n'est
encore officiel non se dirige très
clairement et très certainement vers une
nouvelle hausse du prix du navigo
jusqu'à 3% selon les premières
informations ce qui pourrait faire un
pass navigo à 76 euros par mois et coûté
à ce propos stéphane baudet vice
président du syndicat des transports
d'île de france
ça fait quinze ans que chaque année en
moyenne à 2 25% le pass navigo ou la
carte orange augmente donc c'est pas un
sujet nouveau
et oui il continuera naturellement
d'augmenter la présidente s'est engagé à
ce qu'il n'augmente ce qui est pas ce
qu'était un changement avec ce qui se
passait avant est-ce qu'il n'augmente
qu'avec de l'offre supplémentaire cette
année il a augmenté enfin l'année
dernière il a augmenté de 3 euros nous
avons eu de l'offre supplémentaire
en contrepartie ces salles engagement
politique qui prive dans la présidente
la hausse du passe navigo c'est la seule
piste envisagée non heureusement les
voyageurs n'ont pas être les seuls on va
dire à à payer l'addition
la région regarde ce qui se fait
ailleurs en europe un système par
exemple d'heure plein et d'or creuse
pourrait être mise en place des tarifs
spéciaux pour les touristes également
plus de publicité ou encore un péage
urbain à l'instar pour les voitures à
l'instar du modèle londonien sachez
d'ailleurs votre fric à londres
l'équivalent du passe navigo peut coûter
jusqu'à 415 euros
par mois merci nicolas et puisque l'on
parle de transport et du stif sachez que
le plan d'amélioration des réseaux de
bus poursuit d'ici 2020 15 nouvelles
lignes seront renforcées six nouvelles
seront mises en place depuis le 1er
janvier avec quatre parcours ont fait
l'objet de nettes améliorations dont
l'express sans qui relie les mureaux à
saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
nous passons au portrait du mardi le
cirque zavatta douche et s'installe à
chaque année à saint quentin en yvelines
une semaine pour présenter plusieurs
fois son spectacle des prestations qui
sont orchestrées comme il se doit par le
monsieur loyal de à la compagnie et
c'est le portrait de ce mardi signe à
nicolas landry dans une heure le
spectacle va commencer pour le moment
fredo douchez responsable du cirque
s'occupe des derniers préparatifs et des
dernières vérifications autour de la
piste et du chapiteau à 34 ans fredo a
toujours baigné dans le monde du cirque
aujourd'hui il est à la tête de la
compagnie à bata douche est composé de
30 personnes
je suis ni sur les routes mon père mon
grand père mon arrière grand père depuis
huit générations avec mes enfants nous
faisons du cirque et nous renouvelons
notre spectacle tous les ans car nous
faisons souvent deux fois les mêmes
communes malgré qu'on voyage sur toute
la france et l'europe mais on change le
spectacle comme tous les ans le cirque
si on n'est pas passionné on ne le fait
pas parce que c'est quand même c'est
comme un fermier on a pas on n'a pas
deux jours à nous on est toujours sur
notre lieu de travail c'est tout neuf le
cirque
j'adore aussi bien la mécanique que le
spectacle que ça soit au niveau des
lumières que non de faire des numéros en
piste d'être au contact du public
j'adore ça et le siècle comme je disais
instance et c'est vraiment cette
polyvalent quoi on peut être aujourd'hui
sur la route en train de conduire un
véhicule le lendemain on peut être avec
avec karine est en train de soigner un
animal beaucoup de personnes patientent
devant le chapiteau ils sont venus
découvrir les numéros un spectacle mené
par fredo le monsieur loyal depuis près
de dix ans c'est lui qui met
qui met tous les spectacles en scène qui
voit qu'il n'ya pas deux il n'ya pas de
temps mort on va dire et là où il ya un
temps mort c'est justement là où lui
avec le clown il va combler ses temps
morts pourquoi tu le public décroche au
spectacle c'est moi qui ai la plus
grande gueule on va dire et puis thiam
le mieux est en contact fin j'aime le
plus au contact du public
et puis du coup comme j'ai passé un peu
la main j'étais exhausteurs avant j'ai
passé la main à mon jeune frère du coup
il faut les je me retrouve un domaine et
je me suis mis à commencer à être
présentateur tout doucement je prends de
l'âge et puis je me rends compte que si
j'attends trop je pourrai plus est en
piste il y avait tout à l'heure je fais
équilibrisme et je voudrais encore
changer mon numéro
mais j'ai j'aimerais bien redonné la
main à quelqu'un d'autre le micro on va
dire il refaire des numéros en plus plus
que commandant la famille un élément
important dans le monde du cirque dans
cette compagnie le frère michael douchet
s'occupe des animaux
il est comme moi et des passionnés ce
que je pense c'est que j'espère
continuer comme ça et puis qu'on va
évoluer dans ce milieu là pour moi on
est vraiment complémentaires un camp de
l'autre donc on est vraiment content
d'être ensemble à la fin du spectacle la
pression retombe tout s'est bien passé
à la fin du spectacle je vais d'abord
allé me changer voir si toute l'équipe a
bien rangé le matériel
et puis le boire une bonne tasse de café
peut me réchauffer plus je t'ai fait
froid dehors
le repos est de courte durée il reste
encore du travail pour cette famille qui
parcourt les routes de france
un mot de sport pour refermer ce journal
on prend la direction de guyancourt où
se déroulait la 13e nuit des arts
martiaux le week end dernier au gymnase
des droits de l'homme mais les images
sont signées nicolas d'andry le
reportage michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
car malgré les apparences nous sommes à
guyancourt et non pas en asie la ville a
organisé ce samedi au gymnase des droits
de l'homme sa 13ème rue des arts
martiaux
un événement programmé tous les deux ans
dans la commune le public a pu voir à
cette occasion une dizaine de
démonstration on est fiers on sait tout
le travail que cela représente pour les
associations pour les bénévoles
on sait le temps qui passe a présenté ce
spectacle parce que ça fait pas partie
de leurs attributions première de
présenter des spectacles
ils sont d'habitude ils préparent des
compétitions des cours est donc c'est
vraiment impressionnant tout ce qu'ils
peuvent faire avec les enfants qui sont
heureux d'organiser et de participer à
cette nuit des arts martiaux
au total six associations se sont
réunies pour monter ce spectacle mêlant
sons lumières et performances sportives
pendant plus d'une heure parmi eux le tk
des soixante dix huit spécialités dans
le taekwondo on s'est entraîné sur
plusieurs semaines et plusieurs fois
après les cours après l'entraînement
déjà on s'entraîne et on continue à
s'entraîner pour la démo donc ça fait
puis de deux mois deux mois et demi coup
à peu près qu'on s'entraîne un spectacle
également pour la bonne cause les
recettes de cette soirée seront
intégralement reversés à l'association
et m e alphée une structure basée à
gland cours qui aide les enfants
autistes
c'est la fin de ce journal les
programmes se poursuivre sur tv fil 78
triplet sur notre site internet et sur
notre application mobile
[Musique]